dear vice president xiaomi suivert
honorable members of parliament
millions of ukrainians are seeking
shelter in the european union
torn from their families and country by
putin's bombs
the scenes of war are devastating
but the images of european citizens
welcoming refugees
show another picture
and they tell the story of hope
they show a pan-european wave of
solidarity for our ukrainian friends
because they are part of our european
family
the european union has dedicated 500
million euros in humanitarian assistance
and more will come
we will mobilize billions of euros from
unused funds in the budget
we will mobilize it to help member
states act quickly and humanely
to rebuild reception centers mobile
hospitals and schools for children
and provide employment support for
adults or child care facilities
i applaud the enormous generosity of all
europeans and all member states
especially those boarding ukraine
the european union stands united with
ukraine
but you all know
this is not just a humanitarian crisis
this goes much deeper
russia's war of aggression constitutes a
tectonic shift
in european history
the kremlin has directly attacked our
values and the international order
this is a crisis of european security
and sovereignty
and together we need to rise to this
authoritarian threat
to protect european citizens
and defend not just our democracies
but democracy itself
last week in versailles with president
macron
and the european heads of state and
government
we discussed three strategic areas first
the need for europe to boost its
security and defense capabilities
second
the need for europe to double down on
the green transition
to bolster our energy security against
foreign manipulation
and third the need for investment
and support for european citizens in a
turbulent global economy
this conference is ultimately about
economic governance
but we cannot separate that conversation
from global events
and the eu's strategic priorities
in the last years
we have made significant steps
in stepping up europe's defense
cooperation
but the magnitude of the events we are
facing
represents a watershed moment for europe
as general bulkheart the french chief of
staff of the french army explained a few
days ago
for 20 years we have dealt mostly with
counter-terrorism operations
we are now seeing a conflict on a truly
different scale
end of quote
and he's so right
the military threat to europe has
fundamentally changed
all member states will have to review
their national force structure and
posture
and it is already clear
that we are collectively facing a
massive investment gap
defending europe from russian military
aggression requires a different level of
cooperation
from innovation and development to
procurement and operational use
first we need to collectively identify
the capabilities
that are required to defend europe in
this new strategic reality
second at a deeper level
we have to have another conversation
about the type of defense industrial
base we need in europe as a result of
the russian aggression
the european defense fund
can help to incentivize spending on
common defense projects
and to strengthen the defense industrial
base in europe
but it needs to be strengthened itself
and thirdly
it is important
to identify and close the most pressing
capability and investment gaps in this
sector
systems like air and missile defense
or enhance cyber security
and defense
all those require different level of
cooperation
thus
i will present by may an analysis of our
defense investment needs gaps
and opportunities
both at national
and at european level
it will be crucial that our resources
are invested strategically on joint
european projects
that ensure interoperability in the
field
and enable our defence industry to scale
up across national borders
we need to spend not only more
but more together
it is time for our european defense
union to enter the stage
honorable members this brings me to my
second point
beyond military means europe will only
be secure if we end our over-reliance on
russian gas
we simply cannot rely anymore on a
supplier
that uses energy to put pressure on us
we have to diversify our supply away
from russia and to reliable suppliers
and we have to massively invest in
renewable energy
and the good news is
we have everything in place to act
with the european green deal
the european union is the world leader
in the green transformation
the direction of travel is set
and now we will accelerate
the green transition is a strategic
investment in our independence and in
our security
and this is why last week the european
commission unveiled re-power eu
we will reduce eu demand for russian gas
first by fast tracking new
renewable energy projects including
hydrogen and biogas
second by speeding up investment in
energy efficiency
to roll out
for example solar panels wind and heat
pumps
those are low hanging fruits
as is the insulation of buildings
and third we are diversifying our gas
supplies
the united states norway azerbaijan and
others are stepping up delivery
finally
the investment in lng infrastructure
pays off
because we can use it increasingly for
hydrogen
thus we can end our over-reliance on
russian
gas well before 2030.
we just discussed this intensively at
leaders level in versailles
it is doable and we will go for it
we also discussed in versailles last
week how to meet the momentous
responsibilities we face
and the higher levels of investments
over time
while maintaining fiscal sustainability
investments must be strategic
to strengthen our capacities in defense
cybersecurity energy
critical supply chains semiconductors
health
and food security
and we need to mobilize the private
sector
national parliaments should play a
central role in this conversation
you are the elected representatives of
european citizens
your scrutiny and your commitment are
essential
to turn european investment into local
growth
and to shape the reforms each of your
countries need
your voice will be essential in the
debate on our future economic governance
we need an open debate
and our aim is
to achieve a consensus by the end of the
year
honourable members
the events of these weeks are an
unprecedented test for our union
we have acted with speed and resolve
and we will continue to rise to the
challenge we are facing
together
because unity is our best strength
the coming weeks and months will be
difficult
but together
we can help our ukrainian friends in the
toughest of times
together we can make this war
unsustainable for the kremlin
and give diplomacy a chance
this is what our union stands for
so
long live democracy
long live ukraine
and long live europe